no I think there's going to be an
explosion of demand and I think it's I
mean if you talk about things that can
go wrong my worry is that some as people
learn more about the science and as more
science is done the demand for a
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy will
be so great that it will overwhelm the
number of gods we have with the result
that you'll have lots of charlatans
appearing right hanging out shingles
saying I'm a psychedelic guide right and
you know bad things can happen
you know I mean you were I mean I talked
about how vulnerable you are imagine the
opportunities for you know sexual abuse
and this is actually happening today
people go to Peru for ayahuasca and
you're bad things happen yes yes this is
a major issue in the community right now
actually yeah yeah so there it's it's
not going to be simple you know this is
but this is cultural innovation I mean
this is you know we'll learn in the same
way those those traditional cultures
gradually learn to create the proper
container for the psychedelic experience
our culture needs to do that work too
and it may not be simply the medical
container right you know the white what
I call white coat shamanism I'm we have
our own shamans they're called doctors
and and that makes some people very
comfortable but that it seems to me
would be a little too limited